[Música]
ah
ella está segura de estar
[Música]
sola
nadie va a venir pidiendo disculpas por
la
de mora
[Música]
se siente feliz rompió los vidrios en
tierra
dios imagina para adelante y el río se
llevó es un amor
[Risas]
[Música]
ella está feliz no le ha pedido nada
a la vida
[Música]
estalla la locura
mueren pastillas de razón
ella camina con la tarjeta son ropa
porque ha visto su cara
rota
ella camina con el aire de luchar que no
se sonroja porque ha visto jugador
rota soltar el ratón
para rotar
[Aplausos]
ya está
[Música]
me muero
solo
está ahí
[Música]
suelo solo
[Aplausos]
termina con él
un charquito su sombra
vive
interesa
ella camina con el aire y en un
charquito se es un rojo vive inmersa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno hola soy ver en call me acompaña
martín moreno estamos enormemente
felices por estar acá en este escenario
en este teatro tan épico e importante
para la provincia de córdoba y sobre
todo
en ser parte por primera vez de la
comunidad de decks córdoba
abrimos consola y vamos a seguir con
expulsión una canción que pertenece a
este primer disco que andamos rodando
mostrando lo que se llama ella es una
canción que habla de la violencia en
todas sus facetas en todos sus colores
una pugna de poder
en el afán del control
los gritos y esto y esto no es amor hay
vómito y mucho toda nuestra historia
[Música]
y
disfrutar tu espalda intente borrar tus
lágrimas
tu mirada resquebrajará
y aún así así mi culpa
e
expulsión
un violento
cuántos son
y del vientre de un monstruo
y te conmigo
o no
[Música]
tus pasos de borrar tus
mira resquebrajada
y a vacías y de culpa
expulsión
yo les
en el vientre vino
y conmigo
[Música]
el viento
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
bueno nos despedimos muchísimas gracias
nos vamos a despedir con una cumbia lo
cual espero que si tienen ganas de
bailar la hacer palmas cantarla si se
quiere tiene un coro muy interesante
también al final están todos invitados a
sumarse nuevamente soy bráncoli y me
pueden encontrar en las redes como brent
guión bajo call y nuestro disco está de
descarga gratuita en las plataformas
digitales así que bueno hasta la próxima
y fue realmente un placer poder estar
acá
[Aplausos]
[Música]
intimidad y el sol que brota por los
lienzos poco a poco vas cayendo
poco a poco vas calle puedo demoler
con mi apoyo violento y puedo perder el
tiempo para conquistar ese cuerpo a
dónde van tus ojos cuando estás
a dónde van tus labios cuando me los
estás negando a dónde van tus ojos por
amistad
todos llevan tus
cuando menos estás negando sí es decir
no
más
[Música]
y mía y eso que rozan nuestro cuerpo
poco a poco vas cayendo mientras poco a
poco vas cayendo puede moler tu
todo mi amor
tiempo para conquistar ese cuerpo a
dónde van tus ojos cuando la amistad
cuando menos estás negando algo
ames
no
la
cuando me los estás negando a 2
a dónde van corazón adónde van
[Música]
a dónde a dónde va el corazón a dónde va
ah
a dónde a dónde van corazón a dónde vas
[Música]
o
tú
[Música]
wow
o
a dónde va tus ojos cuando no me estás
mirando
dónde van tus labios cuando menos estás
negando a dónde van tus ojos cuando no
me estás mirando a dónde van tus lara
cuando me los estás llegando a dos
a dónde van corazón
a dónde va
ah
muchas gracias a dormir
a donde el corazón no llega
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah